oui non mais non maritime c'est pas
possible tu viens on va vous me dites et
son frère il ya du talent je pense à
mettre en scène je ne connais pas non
plus je pars en amérique non rappelez
moi oui oui et bonjour à votre mari aux
abris alors oui berlin week-end que
c'est oui à entrer non je suis débordée
qu'est ce que c'est quelle chanteuse
comment elle s'appelle marlène j'en veux
pas revoir au qu'est ce que vous voulez
oui je suis pressé que sia criaient la
part du mois avant de se côtoyer pas que
génère défend voyage à cuba par lewis a
beaucoup de beaucoup de talents shaqiri
oui je vous dis
seule inconnue
je peux faire une étoile et chaud
l'hiver faire une grande carrière
car c'est aussi ça la vie intime de la
gloire ou qui n'est qu'une ombre je vous
ferai lui
non
je tiens dans mes mains les secrets les
ficelles de ce métier de rêve vous
voulez
vous n'êtes scholly moi je vous ferai
belle face il ya tueur est connu dans le
monde entier
je connais tous les producteurs metteurs
en scène et directeur du théâtre et du
music-hall les meilleures pièces les
meilleurs auditoires et danseurs les
auteurs les compositeurs les musiciens
les comédiens je tiens déjà entre mes
mains
galerie peut faire tout ça t'a sugar à
témoin
j'atterris l'amour si vous voulez la
gloire et je serais pour sa première
recrue il faut savoir choisir
il faut souvent vouloir et twitter
stachowiak des marchands de fleurs
à changer de coiffure de maquillage de
vêtements il vous faudra une voiture et
un chauffeur en gants blancs
la liste et apprennent qu'ils
n'attendent pas un mot de moi pour faire
de vous une princesse oui mais sans
comme il se doit
pluton gala
au fait et moi et moi